he's just like this is great for the
blog and I'm unfriend if I have to wake
up and look at our [ __ ] me get me out of
here what you know I'm starting my
one-on-ones but I also realized I'm like
what I'm trying to accomplish may
actually work in smaller formats I did
one two days ago went really really
really well and I want I had a meeting
chance so like basically literally every
if anything happens with like a
cancellation I'm gonna try to do like
shotgun you know like I need to
accomplish people really realizing how
deep I am in the business right so I
think I think one thing I'm spending a
lot of time on is thinking about how
good I am at documenting content and
what that creates right so for me I'm
spending anywhere between 12 and 14
hours a day on vaynermedia right but if
you're an employee and the only thing I
can show in that in my day is my public
Hino or my public interview that I do it
becomes propaganda almost too much in
the other direction so I want to really
just figure out how to get people to
start communicating to me for real
because I think the biggest
misconception that I'm sure of
that I'm gonna spend almost all my time
on is the following I think you know I
think about life as alternatives right
to me everything is what's the
alternative you know there's an I'm not
really ideological or like or I'm not
very like making pretend and so I think
that I have enormous heart and
excitement about what this place is
intent is because I really really really
think that's the most important thing
and then I think about what stems from
my intent all the way down to execution
and it's remarkable to me how many
things I think are broken like an
enormous amount but that comes with
scale and comes with the reality the
business the question becomes how do you
get that proper to me I feel comfortable
as you can even tell in here and I'll
even answer anything like it's funny how
comfortable even at the mercy of like
not having deep relationships with all
of you knowing what you're gonna say
when you go out there and knowing how
fast rumors could
spread I'm still far more comfortable
sitting in this room talking to you for
an hour about stuff that I would be
sending a company-wide email where tone
is always 100 percent why we do so many
videos I'm so scared to send
company-wide emails because an adjective
or two or just literally humans filter
based on their own internal feelings
right so like you literally just you
know so there's just a lot of great
stuff going on I'm very confident and I
feel like I've never had a better grasp
on the things that are super fired or
the things that are an annoyance the
things that are like you know but for me
I just want to get into the hotline
business right like what I'm keep
thinking about every day it's like I
need to create a hotline which is the
biggest vulnerability for me when I
engage its scale is I don't know where
you are between boy that cries wolf and
I'm quitting tomorrow that has been my
unbelievable fascination over the last
seven years because everybody
communicates so differently and you know
we're doing a lot and I'm doing a lot to
try to have a sense but even on a
one-to-one level there's things that I
haven't been able to totally figure out
so I guess the biggest thing I'd like
you to leave here with whether you've
been here for three weeks or whether
you've been here for almost six years is
I've basically made an interesting
commitment to myself somewhere halfway
through last year which is I don't want
anybody to leave this place without
going through me here's why I'll get you
a better job outside of here then you'll
get for yourself and that would make me
feel awesome because I'm so grateful for
you ever working here in the first place
and so like that to that extreme I think
we can really create something because
I've really just watched the people that
have bomb entirely left the company over
the last six months like this is what I
do on my vacations like I went through
it I was like [ __ ] me I'm like no 7 of
these 10 people I have a whole lot of
heart for you know some I just didn't
get to know or you know sometimes people
come in before I get to meet them you
know it's life right but that is the
intent of our organization that's we're
gonna build out you know look to me the
happiness meter in this company is very
simple the closer you are to me the
happier you are at this company
it's just very basic because those
people just know like they're just
they're not drinking the kool-aid they
just see the details we're still number
three hey bro
so releasing pod sessions audio and
video on Friday but we want to drive
back to the podcast on Monday also
introducing Mondays podcast which is
going to be the fireside chat with
bronzer but also want to jump in before
this and make sure you checked out
Friday's and other weekends can get
Friday's pod sessions number two these
pod sessions are straight fire I'm very
excited about it
so if you're just joining me for the
first time ever or you didn't get a
chance to listen to friday's pod
sessions go back and check that out
enjoy the show vlog Vayner beta
literally the greatest use of your money
it's actually true like you know what's
super crazy for DS is amazing and I and
but like the audience of the blog the
number one thing that they should do
like they all want to work with I get a
million emails every day we have a
company it's called we have a division
it's Vayner beta it's four bit how low
can they get in four we've got some
entry-level products like marketing
automation user flows we've got many
campaigns that we do what type like that
very mix 2025 k [ __ ] there you'll get
real like real like real tangible
results not having to sign up for us
person alright enough with the
commercials blog banner banner alright
what's going on can you see this
and I'm doing a pop-up in LA
[Music]
[Music]
when you get traded you get sprayed
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
that's exactly right I'm just looking
for that the email or the text or the DM
four years later saying that quote got
me or that talk changed my trajectory
[Applause]
thank you
[Applause]
just had a three-hour meeting I'm a
private plane with my chief client
officer she's running back to the
airport flying back life's got weird you
know really really hello hello great
what's up man how are the elders powers
such a pleasure to thank you so much for
being a part of this this I don't take
this lightly it's the first time I'm
trying it with kind of like the
conference people and this is gonna be a
lot of fun like I already was laughing
I'm like I've been trying to think about
how the market this because there's no
way in hell I'm gonna stay for just a
limit allocated you know like that
organizers my people my agent they're
like all right two hours you can bounce
out of there like I'm like but I can
stay three hours all right they're like
yeah it's so like I'm excited this is a
real fun format for me the four DS thing
that we've been doing has been a lot of
fun but I'm only in there for like an
hour and having a smaller group and like
I think tonight's me a lot of fun it's
so funny like I grew up idolizing coke
yes your equal as far as why idolize if
I'll see you with Kobe right now I'd be
freaking out I feel like you do such a
good job this is not kissing your ass
I'll probably never see you again the
rest of my life I hope we do
I hope so as well you do such a good job
at just like connecting to me and I feel
like each one of us think this I thought
I had a person with you but I definitely
don't and it's fine it's you know what's
called it's called paying attention it's
hunger just real you're just real I mean
like like I'm still on screen let's put
it this way well I guess we're in front
of you I don't want to I don't want to
yell you'll love this when I'm dinner
with a Jets player who isn't even a big
player I feel the same exact way it's
like whatever you're into right it's
super cool it's the way you connect
let's put it this way when I watch on TV
I feel like I'm in front of you I don't
want to trivialize what this is right
here you ping me a nice Cup win
appreciate I watch you on you too I feel
it
that's a much smarter version I gotta
tell you man
intent is a big [ __ ] like my big like
I'm trying to really understand intent
because I know that like do you know how
unbeatable I feel I will make a lot of
mistakes but [ __ ] I zero negative intent
friction II it's all just friction it's
white voice that's why I will push you
guys all for voice you can reach more
veterans to voice over the next five
years than anything else you got a win
now bill did it
yeah cuz friction like I bought
something today my shower I've got an
Alexa now in my bathroom it's like
literally a limply that's on my bed my
bathrooms the only place I'm in I'm
never in my own home like oh I never
thought of something and I'm open the
door like Alexa I I think that um I
think that this is a super interesting
time and I think that uh I think that
there's so much opportunity and so much
underpriced and overpriced attention and
executing is just like you know
unbelievably important hey good how are
you how are you this is awesome so man
how are you
such a pleasure good to see you brother
awesome hey what are be amazing and we
have some special guests here today it
is my wife Alexa and last but not least
we have Gary Vee in the house welcome to
coil sore my man
for me I want legacy I want all these
people with their handles to think I'm
great to come to my funeral to thank me
on email one day to hang out with me and
VR in 17 years because I brought them
some value I come on here tonight it's
late
I've had a long [ __ ] day we obviously
ran late for the thing that I was doing
first of all thank you for waiting I
apologize to anybody who I was making
wait but this was like you know baboons
like get out of here we got to go to the
next thing and the whole time I'm like
I'm gonna come on and then I come on and
the lights are on and the old that's
running through my mind is [ __ ] I better
say something that brings some kids some
value in st. Louis who actually hears it
a different way from me for the first
time and goes out and actually does
something about it I feel responsible
I'm thankful for the attention and I
want to bring value Wow Wow
now if you really heard what he just
said there's a very powerful secret in
what you just said you you care about
what you're giving you have an intention
to benefit like to look for win-win it's
like it's so deep and it rings so true
to me and I want to tell you just just
because because we came in a whirlwind
and we rushed you on this stage and
thank you so much like you're a warrior
for doing that you just were like give
me a look craw puts the lights on put
the chat on let's go
like beast mode and I know you've had a
long day and you didn't have to come
here but I want to also tell you that I
I read I'm a searcher and I agree with
you a thousand percent it doesn't matter
I call it infinite patience I am gonna
be infinitely patient like when I lose I
just got better like I love that you're
firing me up right now but you wrote one
thing that I will never forget and it
was it was about I'm tired of people
saying thank God is Friday
if you live for the weekends you're your
[ __ ] is broken and people get upset with
me because like no Gary want to spend
time with my family it's not all about
working and I'm like no no you know
understand if you are if you literally
start your week being sad and it gets
progressively better you're in a you
have a problem we spend way too much
time in our lives doing our jobs I lived
that life you understand I'm not I'm T
I'm speaking from a place of
understanding
I lived K through 12 in that life I
lived you know
football fan the fall like school
started and I was devastated after the
Jets game was over I would come from a
huge high that's Sunday because I was
pumped for the Jets to this complete
depression because I knew that Monday I
mean I lived for snow days for like a
decade like for a decade the only thing
I gave a [ __ ] about was please cannanore
Easter come through and illuminate
school right I hated school
right like fighters were forced into
yeah but now I don't and I'm like my god
do people really have jobs the way I
lived school oh my god most people do
and that's what by the way random
thought breaking news I'm starting a
twitch channel where I've been like
thinking about this for like two years
now maybe even three like Justin hit me
up like [ __ ] I've been thinking about
this for like three or four years but
here's what I have to do this is such a
[ __ ] you know why I haven't done it I've
done plenty of like twitch stuff and
hung it this is such a good setup I'm
like wait a minute
why don't I just turn my whole office
into a school you know we have the
master is his name Rick no no Sally no
Shawn Shawn Mendes he's been playing the
same song for three years in a row and I
think it's weird can we talk about this
he's this great by the way he's a really
good kid from what everything I know but
he's been playing the same song for
three years and it freaks me out
three [ __ ] new years in a row Shawn
Mendes is on one of the main stream
channels singing that [ __ ] song do
you know what I'm talking about I know
[ __ ] chat can you guys agree with me
chat can you help me in this but Shawn
Mendes is like a [ __ ] huge [ __ ]
kid he's like a good-looking kid he's a
nice boy just study plays a [ __ ] song
and I'm like I feel like I'm living in
bizarro world because he's like SNL and
[ __ ] New Year's Eve and I'm like
didn't you play that last year and then
like that's fine cuz you know how like
mainstream media is weird and like there
aren't the [ __ ] that's been around for a
year but he's been doing it for three
years you agree right I'm right right I
guess if it's working
[ __ ] snitches no no temporaries right
so this guy's short annoying has
terrible taste amusing we're all really
gonna make millions see this is the part
that I like the most I love this guy no
no really I like temporary Jerry don't
ban him cuz I show you ban somebody I
love him because this is the part that I
love the most right for me
it's on this is why I think I'd be a
good baseball player right because in
baseball if you're out seven out of ten
times you're [ __ ] rolling right Polly
that's right I it's weird to me that
that excites me so much I love it I love
you you do right feed off it so hard
listen you have a different dynamic we
we have our dynamics and what have you
put ourselves out there we're out there
you've you know pretty girls have a
whole nother layer a whole different but
it's still the same game which is you're
either inside your own head or you're
not right like that feeds me as much as
somebody who says I'm the best or I'm
the goat and all that they both feed me
weirdly the same way and I like it and I
really am trying to figure out how to
teach kids that because there's a lot of
kids who aren't putting out great
content aren't enjoying themselves
aren't living because they can't deal
with temporary Jerry fifty-five saying
that you know you're short you're ugly
you're fat you're stupid you suck [ __ ]
you and I'm trying to figure out why do
I hear that and say two things which is
like [ __ ] I feel bad for temporary Jerry
like why like he must be in pain and
like I'd like to become his friend and
make him awesome and to [ __ ] you
temporary Jerry [ __ ] I'm gonna
[ __ ] stick it in your [ __ ] mouth
and I can't wait till I meet you one day
temporary [ __ ] Jerry and you're gonna
be like yo I'm temporary Jerry I'm sorry
I love you you know give me the [ __ ] out
of your bro
he's just like this is great for the
blog and I'm one friend if I have to
wake up in like an hour
[ __ ] me get me out of here what yes
let's hear about your book what it's
really good guys you guys are smart
don't buy it go steal it off a
BitTorrent and read it and [ __ ]
figure out how great it is because this
is the greatest era to talk about [ __ ]
you love and that's what I'd like you to
do I really like you to read it
library BitTorrent don't buy it I don't
need it I just really need you to
understand what's actually [ __ ]
happening and what's actually happening
is the middleman is going away there are
no gatekeepers it is you and the
audience you need to talk about what you
love because everything else is too hard
of work and if you're talented enough
and what you love is interesting enough
you'll make between $1 a year and
[ __ ] 40 million the [ __ ] end
[Music]